>>Derek Pierce: In our first year,
we were often perceived
as all over the place.
We were perceived as we must
be an elite private school only
for gifted kids, to we are a
school for all special-ed kids,
to we are a school that
was a money siphon,
a literal vacuum sucking precious
resources from the rest of the city,
and so it's taken time for people
to understand that we're more
than a sound bite, and it's
complicated to explain what we do,
but we are for all kids, the same
per pupil as other high schools
in the district, and everybody
would complain about what that is,
but we also had to
start with no inventory.
So, we had to with the same amount
of money create new curriculum
and create new possibilities.
We do not have a very
textbook-driven curriculum.
We have some as resources, but we
use primarily laptops for our--
in the role of textbooks in some
senses, and we use the field.
We use the city around us as a
textbook, and we get our kids
out in the field a couple times
a month working with experts
that may range from local
businessmen to, you know, fishermen
and scientists and
university professors
and whoever may be relevant to
the work our kids are doing.
We know that what matters to parents
in the broader community is outcomes,
and so on the two most important
outcomes we've done pretty well.
A hundred percent of our first
graduating class were accepted
into college, seventy-five
percent to four-year schools.
On the state test, which includes
the SATs in the state of Maine,
we've exceeded state and city average
on every single test:
reading, science, math.
That said, we're the last place to
be accused of teaching to the test.
Our curriculum is driven by learning
expeditions, as they are at King.
We do two expeditions each year,
one that's math-science-driven,
one that's humanities-driven.
Those expeditions usually
involve multiple classes.
They may range in length from two or
three weeks to six or seven months,
and they involve kids in
doing what we call real work
for a real audience, work that they--
work that kids are clear that they're
going to change the world potentially
through what they're doing,
one project at a time.
The expedentiary learning allows you
to do kind of in-depth case studies
that have a broader relevance, the
idea that if you look really tightly
at the particular in a
very compelling case study
that you can get the broader
lessons that you can apply all
over the place, so it's very much
a depth-over-breadth approach.
And we pick case studied that we
know will be meaningful to our kids,
from Portland's working
waterfront to a Rwandan genocide,
because we know we have kids who're
going to directly connect to that.
By year's end, every
single kid is up in front
of the school for some reason.
Say it's reading something they've
written, performing something,
paying tribute to another kid.
We have conferences a
couple times a year.
We have a final word, where every
single senior has to give a speech
to the entire senior class about who
they are and where they're going.
We do something similar at the end
of sophomore year, where they have
to present their work to their
peers and parents and outside folks,
so kids have to kind of stand
up and say, "Here's who I am".
So, we really emphasize that piece,
because we think that's a skill
that's very undervalued in schools
and highly transferrable and
helps establish who a kid is
and gives them a confidence
that they can carry on.
It starts with fantastic teachers,
and to me that's potentially
the scarcest commodity
but the commodity that's most
essential to make a great school.
And you have to find people who are--
it's missionary work
doing this kind of work.
It's extremely hard, I think.
Our teachers recognize that
collaborative work leads
to better results, leads to
more fulfilling work for the--
it makes educational work
more sustainable for them,
makes it more rewarding;
however, it's harder.
It takes more time,
and if you're trying
to not only create great
curriculum in your own classroom
but have it sync with
other people's curriculum
and have it all culminate
meaningfully
and meet core state learning
standards at the same,
that's an incredible challenge
like making a great meal.
You got to have the turkey and the
mashed potatoes, and all that's got
to come-- be ready all at once and
all taste good and go well together.
And that's a lot harder than just
making the stuffing, but it's richer,
and so I think our faculty, they
don't want to go anywhere else.
We've been very successful
in terms of turnover.
We have very little turnover, because
people are really thrilled to be
where they are, even though
the work is unbelievably hard.
Our teachers are together for a week
in the summer, and it's essential
to planning the long-term
expeditions.
It's during that week when
they're in their teacher teams,
grade-level teams for a
couple-- just a couple days.
It doesn't take more than that
to get a vision for the year,
and then that vision for the year
is going to change, of course.
It's going to morph, but
it really helps to kind
of anchor the whole year's work.
Without that week, I don't
think we could do what we do,
but it's only a week and it's crazy
that schools don't have 15 days
of staff development, because
that to me is the biggest lever
of change is giving teachers time to
talk to one another about curriculum
and then during the year to talk
regularly about curriculum and kids.
There have to be knowable
communities of learners and teachers
that work together and stay
together for a couple years,
and that can happen through
looping, teaming, advisory practices
and typically all at once.
I mean, to me there is no one
structure that fits everything,
and I think sometimes schools
try to change too incrementally
to make substantive difference,
and you need to have--
if you're driven by a
value like relationships
and you form the structures of your
schools around that kind of value,
then all sorts of structures
are going to change.
And it's the system of those
structures about personalization
and relationships that
really have the impact.
The impacts tends to kind
of grow exponentially
if those structures are consistent
and build on one another.
Too many schools say, "We
can't do the field work.
We can't get the kids out, because
then I'll tick off that teacher
down the hall because I'm pulling
my kids out of their class".
But if you have this team approach
and there's a recognition:
"You know what?
I'm going to do humanities-based
field work, because we all need
to work together towards that end,
but the math-science field work,
that's going to happen this spring.
You'll get more time," and that
kind of negotiation can happen
if you're sharing kids
and sharing purposes.
So, I think given autonomy
to teachers even
in a big school can help not make the
schedule the dictator of learning,
because if it is, you're just
really limiting yourself.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org